we speak i was supposed to be
professor of the opposing but for
personal reasons we talked
to
another
day
and
one with dr
[Music]
and then thank you for organizing this
nice workshop and thank you also for
inviting me
so today i will introduce my recent work
focusing on application so i will
explain how to train i just stand in the
industrial network briefly introduced by
augusto without gradient penalties so
this is trying to work with hidden 124
at ucl la and most london institute and
yonan kim and new zealand at seoul
national university
okay so
here is today's outline so i will
briefly again introduce your stand
generative editor networks and i will
briefly um talk about some
with literatures and then i will
introduce our comparison-based training
algorithm and then i will give you some
experiment and then
some remarks as well as ongoing books
all right
so yeah thanks to augustus i can
briefly explain these generative
addresses networks guns
so these networks have been remarkably
success in generating synthetic images
so in the original model by good fellow
pedal
so we have two networks the generator
and then also discriminator they compete
each other so we are solving the
following minimax problem and the
original model this 3 is given as
follows
so
more precisely we have given real images
okay so given real images and then we
also have
n dimensional noise vector
and if we consider like after
um push forwarding this noise vector to
generator we will get generated image
and then this grantor can tell if this
image is real or fake so this is the
basic idea of gans
and
the washer stain again
the red part here the maximum over
discriminator d
is the wider stand distance so more
precisely our training objective here
is the washers and distance to the
target distribution
so formally the main objective of washer
stain gun can be understood as follows
so we have two constant and then m m is
less than or equal to n and then we have
two distribution so mu is a target
distribution and then here rho is a
source distribution so like for instance
mu can be understood as a distribution
of real images and then rho can be
understood as a noise distribution like
gaussian distribution
then our goal is the following
to find a parameterized generator g so
that washer stand distance between mu
and then g push forward row is close to
zero
so
as you may know well
computing the rajasthan distance has
been a difficult test so
there are a lot of works related works
including the ones in audience online
also here
and i'm sorry that i couldn't like
include all the
um works but
yeah let me say let me also say that
it's my great honor to speaking product
in front of you
so um the popular works is in your
network is as
um dogs to explain the synchron distance
so first of all this algorithm is faster
than computing the
wi-fi same distance the actual larger
stream distance so it is i would say it
is useful
in machine learning and also um the last
work by matt here and also for lobbying
and in this work um they use controversy
potential to compute the watchers time
distance between
sorry i should say the country's duality
formulation to compute the larger sign
distance between two measures and
there are much more works regarding this
okay so since computing the right
sustain distance is
a difficult task so instead of that
if p is then p is one then we may
consider the following
simple formulation so
in the original paper of washington
dance
this is so-called wifi stain weight
clipping so they clamp all the ways to a
fixed box so that this phi here so the
only condition we need is five yes a
legit function so as long as the weight
is small enough then we can make
we can make it lift its function
but the problem of this approach is this
can overly restrict the class of
functions
so
then the next one is so-called wngp so
this is i should say um works pretty
well and this is a nice model
but the but the problem is
as you see
so
gradient of b5 the norm of gradient
d5 is not necessary to be one globally
so
and then another problem here is
applying the gradient penalty at some
sample points is not sufficient so this
is not this is exp experimentally shown
so the question main question is how can
we take this measure omega so we have
two measure and then
um like there are actually many
different approach regarding this we may
consider the interpolation of mu and
then the generated measure and then we
can also consider
other interpolations
and another analytic and interesting
work is
the following recent work so this
problem in fact compute the minimum of a
different optimal transfer problem
related to congest congested transport
so
yeah
then
our question is following so how to
estimate the larger same distance and
also as well as how to make algorithm
perform well in the generative setting
and also how to enforce the leashes
constraint efficiently so this is what
i'm going to talk about today
i should also mention other
like list of w gangs so i think the
first one is related to simone's last
question so instead of the grading
penalty term we we may consider the
maximum of zero and then the following
the norm square minus one so and
there is actually like um the second
work
in in addition to gradient penalty term
we can add some kind of um lift sheet
norm so that which is constant is
forced well
but the problem here is still we need
gradient penalty term
and another work um
by
antone and also guido and agusta here so
we can also use contribution dlt
formulation w grant based on c transform
and this method allows for a more
accurate estimation of the true watchers
and distance but as
discussed before it does not perform
well in the general setting and this is
exactly the same figure that um you
shown in the last slider and
augustus talk
all right so uh let me introduce our
comparison-based training algorithm
so we will i will explain um two simple
but important just ideas
so let us recall the original
formulation of w and distance and as you
may notice
like the maximizer of this so the
country's potential phi can actually
take any values at
the
complement of support of u union with
supplements support of nu
as long as five leaves each
so that means instead of literally this
condition we may consider the following
audience of a condition so instead of
whole domain we may it is enough to
consider the support of mu times the
support terminal
so it is uh actually clear that if the
both support are equal to omega then
this condition is equivalent to
one if it's conditioned but which really
happens in real world data
and also
this using this instead of the original
diffuse condition is more efficient if
the support of mu and support nu is
let's say they are small enough
and then what happens instead of the the
original diffuse condition but using
this previous condition of doing some
condition a you can actually see that
if as long as we have this condition we
can use
the duality relation so that
the one we compute here is also
essentially one larger same distance
okay so this is um
first idea so this is again um maybe i
should say simple and also well known
but
this will help us to compute underwater
same distance as well as
train w gas
and the second i second idea is also um
related to
like training what you're saying guns so
in practice one does not have access to
the true distribution instead when we
compute the c transform we can only
consider a set of points
so
like here when we compute
the c transform of phi we may only
consider
the euthymum over x in the support of mu
n and here mu mu n is a an empirical
measure
so this approach actually is widely used
in literature
but in fact this c transform on a
smaller set let's say on the support of
one measure which is different from the
original one so
the difference is
just
um in the in
in the c transform on the support of me
eta we take infimum over
x in the support of eta and then in the
original c transform
we take x infimum over the whole domain
omega
so using these two ideas so instead of
this condition we use um the orders of
condition a and then instead of also the
original c transform this is actually
not easy to compute so instead of that
we only consider the c transform on mini
batches
okay
and
there are yeah there are differences
between the original c transform and
then c transform mini branch so
the maybe the main difference is if phi
is least function then
in the original state transform pi c is
for sure minus phi
and also we have the following
dual deformation however
this relation doesn't hold in general
and as a consequence
phi c is not necessarily equal to minus
phi even if phi is a licious function
and this is actually the main idea of
our algorithm
okay
then
what happens if we consider instead of
the original c transform and
the c transform minivan
so
consider two empirical measures now we
consider the summation
so sorry the average of
n delta measures
and then these are all
our objective function
and it is clear that if our phi
satisfies the elements of condition a
then we do have the following relation
so minus 5 is less than or equal to 5c
then also that means it is clear that we
can compare j1 j2 j3 and j4 as follows
because it is enough to compare for
instance when when we compare j1 and j2
it is not to compare minus phi and 5c
and equivalently so this above lambda
means that equivalently if j1 is greater
than j2 or j1 is greater than j3 then
phi does not satisfy the condition
and similarly if j1 is
less than or equal to j2 for all
empirical measures then phi satisfy the
items of property a so
the comparison between j1 j2
so let's say j1 is less than or equal to
j2 is equivalent to the audience of
condition
all right so
here is our algorithm
so we like to
we like to solve the following problem
so here
um i only use
i i just use any measures not like
um your network but
we like to solve the following problem
so if you over all new property measure
and then the supremum over
this measure is
i should say like j1 in our case so our
objective functions are here and then we
want to
restrict phi
to
um
satisfy the
atoms of condition
so the idea is following so since we
want j1 is always less than equal to j2
and then j1 is always less than equal to
j3 and then we know that our phi
satisfies the identical property
so
nu being equal to be the minimizer
so
yeah
new is a given measure
and then you like to
find new
so like in theory view since we
solved
like the
the one here is the watchers and
distance between mu and nu so in fact um
if
nu is mu then the one here is zero
but since um
new year's parameterized by like your
network
so
yeah this
like
this
um
you mean
like
so we want to minimize the larger same
distance so that that is the main object
and then here what i did is we slightly
like change
the produce of a condition so instead of
the one mission list we consider phi
satisfies the condition a
does this answer
true that if i is it was conditionally
then minus five also satisfies it right
um this is slightly different but yeah
yes i i think um if you're
you're saying that if new is
like
mu sorry nu is mu then this this part is
zero and that that is true
or
the minimizer of this problem or
inside p omega
yeah so the support of mu is
a container
[Music]
the original problem is actually yeah we
we don't we cannot just find
mu
nu but we need to find some generator g
and then we want to find g
so
so nu need to be replaced by g push for
some noise manager like what role
you're using a more restricted class
yes yes right exactly
any other questions
yeah thanks a lot for the comment
okay so
let's go back to the algorithm then
so the inequality we need is j1 is less
than or equal to j2 so if this
inequality does not um
like
it's not satisfied then we want to
increase j2 so that's why i use um adam
here and in fact i i just wrote for
simplicity maximize j2 but
um more precisely more precisely this
increases j2 so that j1 is less than j2
and we do similar jobs here
and then if we have the right
inequalities then
we maximize j1 so this is exactly
solving the first problem and then
lastly we need to also again minimize j1
with respect to the cell so yes sorry
here i i didn't like include the
parameter and then your network here but
in fact like phi here is parameterized
by sata
and then this is one neural network and
then here we is also parameters by
ceta which is another network more
precisely with nu is like g push forward
row
okay
then i want to do some experiment here
so that
um
so here i consider two mixtures of four
gaussians so you can see the yellow
points and then also green points
so the contribution potential phi
can be computed as follows so this here
um this figure shows the values of
contribute
as well as the level set you see that um
this is symmetry so
you can easily check that the optimal
map from let's say one green point to
yellow point is perpendicular
perpendicular to the level set here and
like for instance
like w and gp so c transform we have
actually a similar figure so this method
also
has made the washer stain distance well
so
and then if you use other algorithms
then
you can see that this
has
not correct not accurate contours
potential
this is our loss function as well as j1
j2 j3 and j4 so
we have um total five functions j4 w j3
j2 j1 and you see that
if
we
train the washer stain guns then these
holes
like quantities converges
and interesting part here is
also wn gp with gradient penalty it
stabilized but you see that this
actually doesn't converge and this is
somehow expected because the leash is
constant
is not in fact one and if we add more
restrictive condition lambda is 10 then
this
quantities
are closer than the previous one
and what about the c transform in the c
transform um here
like if i understand correctly then
we only use j two
so that means j two actually converges
well but we have actually small gaps
between other quantities
and another
interesting part here is what happens we
only consider a small number of points
so we solve the exactly same problem but
with mini batches a minimum to size
eight so
we use um
the same the two gaussian mixture of
2000 mixtures and then you can see that
in our algorithm we can also have
compute the
country's potential accurately
and also we can also compare um the norm
of b5 so here if
the color is white then it means the
normal d5 is close to one
and maybe another like point is the
point here like on the vertical axis
like x-axis so this is in fact where phi
is not differentiable so
we can also capture this
all right and
this actually works through in high
dimensional data so we sample five
thousand images of digit one and then
also five thousand images of digit two
and then
this also um
like converges so every old quantity is
converted as well
and
so actually this this will result here
similar to the ones with a synthetic two
dimensional datas
okay so this was our first task and
the second one is um second task is
perform well in the generative setting
so
the
from left to right the training data was
feminist and then
fashion amnesty and
c for pen so you see that visually the
genetic images are of similar quantity
but our algorithm actually runs faster
than
this algorithm because we don't need to
compute the gradient within than phi so
yeah in fact it is hard to find
which one is good and which one is bad
so
there is one
measure which is called um fib
metric so this is
i i cannot say that this is um like
maybe f like effort or
measure to
quantify the quality of images but this
is just on the square y-system metric
between two multi-dimensional gaussian
distributions so when we compute this
distance we use
mean and also
variance of distributions
so
and this is standard metric
in this framework and you see that like
our algorithm as well as wgp also
converges to
zero well and also they are actually
really similar
and the last thing i
was actually very interested in is we
like to enforce delicious constraint and
this is
done
by computing the following so the
supreme of um
delicious constant
and
you see that in wngp in fact the least
constant is much
less than
uh less than one and also
we do have some oscillation but it is
like between like let's say
1.5 and then also
like 2.5
so these are um experimental result and
so how many
okay so then let me just give you um
maybe one one remark which is also
um related to previous
figure here
so
recall the c transform method so
this is similar um the left one is
using j2 as objective function and this
problem
you see that has
the following blurry images
and
i'd like to understand this more so let
me just
interchange the supremum and then
expectation then we will get one more
same distance
and the question is whether an optimal
mu is similar to the given property mu
and in fact
this this on this problem
in fact calculate the empirical distance
empirical washes and distance between
two empirical measures
so in fact um one can check that the
answer is no
as illustrating the following lemma so
like for instance when we consider very
simple case so we consider one point as
a mini batch and then we also consider
like one dimensional data and one can
check that this can be the median can be
a global minimizer of the the problem so
this is um
like just speaking also
um related to the k-means clustering so
in fact this c transform method
probably a compute
or
like probably similar to clemens
clustering
so then what happens here is instead of
the original problem if we add
the washer stain the empirical washer
stain distance then probably we we may
control
the centrality so if epsilon is zero
that
i
um i presented earlier so in this in
this problem um our images are sharp and
then if
we use instead of j1 so this is an
objective function
if we use j2 and j3 then we have blurry
images so that means we can if we choose
a perfect epsilon then we can control
the centrality or let's say the
blurriness of images so that's one point
and like another point is actually w
grants with the two butchers and
distance so this actually has many
advantages in theoretical prospective
slr applications
however um
um yeah so there are like not many works
in this
respect so
if we can compute if we can use the two
alternate distance then maybe we can
compute optimal math map and also
we may cons may use this as
one tool to compare with the watches and
gradient flow
so this is also like another like
direction i'm
interested in
so in summary um our algorithm in first
one washer is 10 bound and then without
the need of introducing the grand
penalty so that's our main goal today
and consequently we need we don't need
to worry about the parameter so we still
need to worry about
the structure of neural networks but we
don't need to worry about the parameter
in front of
the penalty term
and also
this algorithm generate
realistic images well in many
like
these types of datas
so
thank you for your attention
thank you any question
i may have just missed this but how do
you evaluate decisions for in your
training
yeah so because that's
so
as i discussed earlier in
this slide
yeah
so here what happens is this mu n is the
summation of 10 delta functions
and so that means instead of equivalent
it is not to use
the minimum
over these
x size
so this is how i compute the circuit you
evaluate
this for every x 9 and just pick the one
so you do this with batch
mismatch
and do you observe likely a lot of
observations going on if you choose a
very small batch size
uh you mean
change yes
because
in principle this season 4 has to be
evaluated over the whole data center
right if you just use a batch it's
really biased i mean there's induced
bias there yeah so
yes yes that's a good point and then
that's why in
our experimental result there there are
some oscillations okay and then um
in fact um
so
if we can compute the original c
transform then
maybe we can we can use that to
train the network but here the main
problem is since it is not easy to
compute the c transform so instead we
use this quantity and then this is since
we are working on like
many different mini batches then
eventually this can enforce the
condition we need so
you still have bias it's not like a i
mean normally when you do batch the
reason you can do battery is because
it's unbiased this unbiased estimation
but because you have a female over there
automatically it's biased
so and no matter how many batch you use
eventually you would have bias for sure
yeah yes yes yes yeah so like
maybe in our results so it also
like for that reason so it depends on
our
um
let's say
the time step
so yeah we do we do have oscillations so
that's that is exactly um how i compute
based on the c transform mini batch so
we do have oscillation that's that's
true and then this oscillation becomes
larger if
the step size is bigger
okay
okay thanks
one more question
maybe this is related to this slide how
do you evaluate the kind of performance
in the end because if i uh okay you only
have sample digits let's say and if i
had a mapping that precisely maps you
know i have a neural network which is
over parameterized i can represent
anything let's say i map my initial
distribution maybe it's a gaussian mu
exactly just the sample points so now
you know when i wherever i want to draw
something i perfectly draw already one
of the sample points and if i measure
what is the vast extent distance it's
going to be very very small right
so how do you kind of evaluate whether
we have done well whether this is
generating something that is out of the
sample because i guess collapsing to the
sample is not
not what is desired thanks
yeah so yeah that is actually um i think
a very very great point so
when you just estimate the watcher same
metric and then let's say that two
measures are like far from each other
then we can have like this kind of
figure in our data
however
after
when while training w gains used to
measure eventually converges so
i mean that's the side hole
and so
this can also measure for
um
the quality of our synthetic images but
in fact we need to we need to see if our
like measure is
like close to zero
however um in fact that's yeah that's
that's actually um not easy question i
think so in our experiment our loss loss
function like j1
um converges i mean it is
actually not easy to say because
um it
goes to zero but i can't say that this
is actually zero
so
so in in this sense i think that this
like um like visual inspect inspection
is one way but but with visual
inspection i have no way of knowing if
these points are already in the sample i
mean i don't have a visual kind of
understanding of such big data set right
so
yeah so
yeah yeah i should say that um
[Music]
so your question is
if the loss function converges to zero
then can you say that our
algorithm works well or not
or
well i would say if it goes to zero that
means that what you're generating are
already sample points right
yes yeah yeah but the problem is um
first of all
so it is hard to compare with other
previous algorithms because for instance
in wngp that algorithm actually um don't
compute the one muscle same distance
so our algorithm
the loss function goes to zero but it is
it is actually still clear if this means
our
like our images
has good quality or not
yeah maybe we can discuss all right i'm
really kind of uh you know i i see that
gans are you know doing something well
but i don't quite understand what uh so
thanks
[Music]
but did you
like when you do the comparison with the
wngp i guess is the previous slide so
are you using the same set of hyper
parameters
of the wngp paper
uh yes
so except the lambda parameters but we
don't need that and then also um in fact
in our algorithm so in wgp we need to
like in the so the number of iteration
is slightly different because we we
don't actually need more iterations so
that's different but other parameters
are same
so the tradition is that we get the last
question
apparently
okay
so
my question was related actually to the
uh to the c transform that you
compute with the mini batches
so do you think that
in some way so because
[Music]
when you start from
any phi and you just do the c transform
on the whole support
you do like three times and then you
stop and then and then that's it
right because uh
it's an evolution yeah but
if you do it uh you know with the
synchron algorithm then it reaches to
to the optimal
now this seems to me
in somewhat it's somewhat a noisy
version
of the c transformer could it be that
it works in some way when you know
doing iteratively
changing batches and maybe you know
enlarging the batches
you are converging in some somewhat to
the minimum
yeah so
that's actually um but i'm also curious
so our algorithm
in some sense can be also understood as
the
regularization so like and one of
regularization is the single algorithm
so um
in in that sense
so maybe
um okay so let me let me first say maybe
one practical advantage and then also
i'm curious if we
repeat
um
this algorithm and then find the optimal
condition optimal contribution potential
then can we somehow show the convergence
so that that's one thing and another
thing i should say is in in this
area at least in the
um
let's say
estimating the watchers ascertain
distance um since we can compare like
objective functions so that actually
makes us easy to choose appropriate like
parameters so i think that is one
advantage of our algorithm but this also
can be understood as one of the
regularized sedation methods to
train w glands
so i suggest we stop here so thank you
again
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
so thank you very much to ever so
everyone